that's what a flash flood looks like
it's not every day you see a river there
in the desert
incredible video sent to us from darren
gravely you could barely hear him over
the wind
you can see the water just running down
the mountain this is not too far from
calico basin out at red rock
good evening and thanks for joining us
here at five i'm denise valdez and i'm
brian loftis plenty of damage the past
24 hours here in the valley including
downed trees ripped up carports and
flooding
we have team coverage for you from all
over the valley
chief meteorologist ted florento here in
studio tracking all weather changes
sally jaramillo is in anthem in
henderson with a look at some of the
damage
but first madison kimbrough leads our
coverage in pahrump
madison yeah we just arrived at the
parump
valley speedway and i want you to take a
look at this damage because you can see
this is the main road here on
pam arana road and you can see major
flooding going on really hard for cars
to even
drive by or even get to the speedway on
our way here construction crews were out
clearing the roads as there was a lot of
flooding on our way up
we plan on speaking to the people at the
speedway about the extent of the damage
from the pictures that were sent in it
looks like the roof caved in
trees were down we did see broken
windows as well
so as you can see just really major
flooding over here and i think that
this is the least of it compared to what
people were getting earlier i mean the
roads were really intense
people trying to drive through that
water was crazy just seeing those videos
so keep it here at 8 news now as we
bring you the latest coverage going to
send it over to henderson
with sally so she can tell us about
weather coverage over that way